welcome to this video playing a Nino
from Spain let's see Amin oh okay gotten
that Stonewall set up in not very
attractive form with white having not
played the fianchetto but with e3 that's
a quite comfortable form for white let's
see sorry yeah I can also take here and
play 95 one possibility that some in
fact it's more than one interesting way
to play here for white okay so just f4
here yeah wonder if here maybe can play
e5 at the right moment
hmm maybe hmm I played this a bit too
quickly or an F for you would be able to
take and play you five
hmm that's not so bad for black rabbit
still it's hard to not player for you
yeah he can take and play five
yeah yeah not doing that is quite risky
this no is rather one-sided yeah this
was a bad bet move water at least with
Bishop takes e4 interesting I thought
that bishop you should be 8 h5 would
have been now would have been impossible
a team okay if we now just trade
everything off where this is Queenie one
hopes I have for attention attention
attention need to color you want first
yeah all this I mean maybe you can even
play your five and wow what a bad game
our bad game is wrong I'm blaming the
game but my play is the problem check
you know I think I can just about just
about hold this check yeah I have well
here f is protected whoo
I guess there was a win for like I'm
pretty sure I'm pretty sure there was
something bad had possible okay how do I
play this maybe he and Queen G for up to
two to activate and then the King maybe
come up Queen traders is just leading to
a very nice end game with very one-sided
play needs to play Queen h8 at age six
anyway oh I can take it six actually hmm
then I think I really can take it okay
he's accepting the endgame
so let's see it that's of course quite
nice with the night against the bishop
well first move the King up here so that
his King needs to go to f6 I think oops
really okay wants to play h6 I see okay
check
you know it's it's very critical Queen a
kicking age six okay yeah okay but I
must play h4 I guess okay I can I can
also go here first his pawn age four I
can just play King g5 and win it and so
I can let him do the movie em ya know I
can just go to g3 right and pick pick up
the edge pawn I don't even need to break
through on the Queen side now
this was a very bad position probably
totally lost right when I had the G file
opened far to play this far to check
superficially
black resigns yeah we can now look at
the the disasters yeah this is here this
is a bedroom for water simply now maybe
a tick here in 95 I mean I take I need
to take and play 92 where this is
actually what is right and then F for
coming I have three better have three
yeah yeah this is now not not great at
all yeah and here he can just take I
mean this is the first spot where where
it was very tricky no e5 this is just
happening very quickly with a very bad
position
whoo okay well here right here I
probably should have watched you three
yeah King h8 was stronger but even this
is probably probably very problematic if
I've no lien if I've and white white
resides with Bishop g4 coming yeah it
was a disaster really was check and here
everything's back to check to being okay
giant here we must play Queen f5 maybe
yeah well this is just very one-sided
now and he made some some further
inaccuracies allowing this already is
very problematic I think black is lost
here this is this is too much yeah now
92
into g3 picked up picked up the pawn but
even if he does not go over with the
King I mean I expected here that he
would cover the the King side but there
is always this this breakthrough coming
and that's very very problematic for
black because white will have further
attacking targets
you know like b7 and c6 and you know I
don't really think this is defensible
and the long run would put be very
simply very surprising a bit of it would
be but you have a very shaky game I just
played it far too quickly and
superficially out of the opening okay
thanks for watching